bonjour à tous je suis ses coûts et les
spectacles le parlement européen ça vous
dit quelque chose c'est sert à mettre si
j'ai cette semaine alors le parlement
européen qu'est ce que c'est il est
parlement européen est une des plus
anciennes institutions européennes
monsieur cette province 13 bourgault
cross
strasbourg et des symboles arik s'élance
de la réconciliation franco-allemande le
centre historique de la ville et tout en
tics là c'est un d'une escaut le talent
est d'euros comme la cathédrale de
strasbourg en sont les monuments
emblématiques
le temps le mot est la seule institution
dont les membres font directement élue
par les citoyens des 28 états de l'union
c'est à dire par vous
mais qui sont les parlementaires il
siège au parlement et font de l'ombre de
751 députés élus pour cinq ans
directement en lice citoyen et comme
président élu par les membres de
l'assemblée pour deux ans et demi
le parlement européen est constitué de
sept groupes politiques les députés du
siège nous à part nationalité mais par
affinités politiques
à quoi sert le parlement européen le
parlement est chargé de représenter et
défendre les citoyens auprès des
dirigeants et des institutions de
l'europe c'est en cet allié crucial de
décision mais aussi de dialogue
quels sont les pouvoirs du parlement
européen
premièrement de participer à
l'élaboration et 1,9 probation des lois
dans de nombreux domaines comme le
transport énergie agriculture
ce pouvoir est partagé avec le conseil
de l'union européenne
deuxièmement il va contrôler les
dépenses du budget européen
troisièmement ils veulent vérifier que
les autres institutions respectent bien
les doigts
quelles sont les priorités du parlement
européen
le parlement a pour but de protéger les
libertés et la démocratie
il se préoccupe également de la
protection des droits de l'homme par
exemple avec la promotion de l'égalité
femmes hommes il défend aussi la culture
européenne par exemple les programmes
européens pour la mobilité des jeunes
tels que le programme erasmus
concrètement que fait le parlement
européen pour nous lie décision du
parlement aux influences votre vie de
tous les jours c'est par exemple grâce
au parlement que nous sommes remboursées
quel que soit le pays de l'europe où
l'on tombe malade et où l'on se fait
soigner
les nouvelles voitures devront dès 2015
être équipées d'un dispositif d'appel
d'urgence coe cas d'accident
les citoyens européens tels changer
d'avis ou se faire rembourser dans un
délai de 14 jours lorsqu'ils achètent un
bien sur internet
vient la réunion le parlement européen
pour quoi ça sert vous saurez tout dans
notre prochaine émission à bientôt